oh I'm up to about six cans a day high
GQ it's me Trixie Mattel and these are
my essentials
[Music]
this is such a sad item this is my
Nintendo switch and this is really great
for touring because everybody on my tour
bus has one of these and so we all play
games like Smash Brothers we play Mario
Kart I love dead by daylight I love to
play Friday the 13th I'm like 3/4
through breath of the wild my last tour
before growing up I was playing Skyrim I
don't think that game even has an end I
quit after a while I was like we get it
there's dragons and there's no modern
medicine and so I kind of moved on but I
love mice which got to be glued
hairspray I've been using this hairspray
since I started drying in 2008 it's lit
every drag queen uses these if you have
like real hair this is quite a
commitment cuz this is the type of
hairspray that like once you view this
on your real hair you're gonna either
need to shower or like comb it out to
the point where you're gonna see white
flakes coming out of here cuz this is
like spring glue into your hair I mean
if you look at this nozzle this is the
same nozzle you use to try to contain
like a swarm of bees when you're taking
down a nest so if that lets you know
what this does to your hair but it's
really great when you're wearing as much
synthetic hair piled on top of your head
as I do you really need something that
you can count on me a lot of people
think when they really need something to
stay they like soak one area but all
hair sprays are made to be used 8 to 12
inches from your head so by the time the
hairspray leaves the can some of the
alcohol goes away so it's actually more
effective I buy it on Amazon and I buy
like twelve that one ok I once worked
with its drag queen I don't want to say
who it was because it was Vicki box but
I would see that maybe like take a shot
of booze and then they would say I'm
putting on my personality so like me
before the meet-and-greet
I will shock them one of these like a
frat boy and like punch a hole through
the wall and then go hug teenagers the
taste in the ritual of it really gets me
and like the pre-show mindset only
problem is these are carbonated and so
like when I'm in a corset backstage
about to go on and sing by shotgun one
of these you burp a lot
the yellow kind is my favorite what
would you call it tropical it's lit the
normal kind to me tastes like Duracell
battery get this
this is a really good perfume it's
unisex and I really like this cologne
because if I'm trying to like get out of
drag if I still like walk in somewhere
and this is still like on my body I'm
not like embarrassed it's not like I
have women's perfume on out in public
I've been using it for probably ten
years people still compliment me on it
all the time it's a little strong a
cologne you want to wear when you want
people to smell you but it's great for
drag it's called your kwatak and I think
it's supposed to have like a clean water
scent when there's pictures of the
seaweed on it to me it smells like what
you'd hope you'd smell like coming out
of a swimming pool clean clean water
with like maybe a twist of citrus I just
love it beautiful I grew up in the
country which means my dental care for
the first 25 years of my life was iffy
to moderate for somebody like me who
lives in fear of getting like advanced
gingivitis this is a mouthwash that has
no alcohol
so if washing your mouth with alcohol
kept you from getting cavities mama I'd
be fine
sometimes if I just like I'm like I
can't I can't do the whole bedtime
routine I can at least do this swish
swish and then on the tour bus I can
like wake up and swish this and I know
that between my bedroom and the venue if
I run into somebody I'm not going to be
like embarrassed of the way my head
smells so it's a great product I love it
I guarantee Amazon it by like three at a
time
oh hello this is my guitar every tour I
get a new guitar this one is a Gibson
hummingbird how many birds are great
because they have this like beautiful
like iconic hummingbird design here and
I learned to play guitar for my grandpa
on hummingbird I remember being a kid
and being really small and thinking this
was like huge now as an adult it's so
little to me but um I just love this
instrument hummingbirds are a few inches
shorter than most guitars too so the
actual like length from here to here is
like a couple inches shorter that's
great for travel it's a really popular
guitar in like American rock music and
sounds like a really like mellow but
also like very talented
[Music]
guess snap horribly like this
[Music]
this is a Malibu skipper I don't
actually travel with a lot of dolls um
who does but I get all my I get him his
gifts and I collect mostly sixty five to
seventy three and this I believe is a
1971 Malibu skipper you can tell because
this is right when they changed the
plastic to like a super tan nobody
really believed in like skin cancer
melanoma so all the dolls are sold in
like swimwear with super tan legs
because they were like what's the worst
that could happen
plot twist I got this as a fan fan gift
and I probably have three of this exact
doll already but I'll keep her I'll put
her in a different outfit she's um she's
probably worth I mean she went to a
dealership you could probably get her
for like 45 bucks I mean she's not worth
the most the most varied all I have I
have a black francy which they only made
a few of I have a black Francie in the
box with the shipping label on it she's
probably about a $4,000 doll and you
know that seems like a lot because it is
so if you guys come see grown-up or you
buy barbara now you know what i'm doing
with your money
I always travel with a bunch of my
Trixie cosmetics because even though I
tested these way before they came out
whenever I'm on tour I still like to
keep them on my rotation because I need
to be able to take pictures myself in
them to send to like our social media
team some pens have my office staff send
me new formulas to try on the road and
it's nice to have some of our current
products to try along with it so I can
see the difference in shade finish
formula etc so we have a few here we
have a material girl we have skipper
which is really a staple that's really
pretty pink and then we have a Malibu
which I was writing Malibu with a song
around the time this was being worked on
so there is some like marriage there and
then slime time we actually released
this green one for Halloween and it was
so popular that we put it in the
permanent rotation so it really helps
when you own your own company to like
try to pay attention to what people
respond to because sometimes a product
like this which was meant to be limited
edition people like nut for and then
you're like I should probably keep that
around and then this is Stacy's mom
which just came out yesterday
I have it on now you can tell it's like
pink but not like neon it's like a
patent leather magenta this is my iPad
rich it's coming alive now I'm not proud
of it I probably lose two of these a
year they just are so little I'm thin
and I use them for everything so they
get they slip through the cracks
I keep all my jokes I've ever written in
one like Google Doc so if I ever get
hacked my career is over and I also have
the entire script for my show growing up
on here I also have whatever lyrics to
whatever songs I'm working on I also
have some some weird fun stuff like I
have this game called dream daddy which
is a dating simulator where you date
people's dads so if that lets you know
we're touring takes me mentally
sometimes it's good to be able to unplug
Oh
eBay and I have easy out here because
one of my favorite activities on tour is
doing deep eBay dives for like weird
retro toys that I love to buy so and I
have my wall presents plus network on
here so I can watch every week's episode
of because even though I work for a
while presents I still have to buy my
own membership I'm not
[Music]
so how do I stay so thin you ask every
day my assistant Brandon wakes me up
with a black tea a banana and a green
juice during the day you have to eat
very strategically because if you're
about to go perform and sing and squeeze
your body to death to go on stage you
really can't like eat much so a product
like this that's just like a hundred
percent juice I know that I'm gonna get
like a pretty modest caloric intake but
I'm gonna get a lot of the stuff that's
gonna get me through the day like apples
and celery and cucumbers and when you're
in drag you have lipstick on a juice
like a liquid meal is sometimes the
difference between eating and not eating
at all so yes I live like an astronaut
but that's I make a lot of sacrifices to
be Trixie this is an Elmer's washable
school glue stick in disappearing purple
if you don't know drag queens use this
to cover their eyebrows because this is
like a non-toxic quick drying
water-based polymer that coats your
individual brow hairs and when you layer
it it can actually cover up the texture
I'm not a very sweaty person some drag
queens use like pros eight or more of
like a prosthetic adhesive for this its
skin safe and it comes off in the shower
they have to make this product so that
kids could like eat it and not die I
don't really care what happens to the
kids but I'm happy that this comes off
and last but not least I have entire
half days my life where I don't have to
be in drag and usually because I'm
wearing this much makeup and like um
adhesive all over my face and glue and
really high impact pigments staining my
very fair alabaster skin I like a
product like this to wear on my days off
so this is milk makeup skin sunshine
skin tint SPF 30
so does a sunblock it has moisturizing
qualities and it has a very slight tint
to it so even though it's my day off I
can still make sure I cover things like
stains are on my lips from lipstick or
areas my forehead where maybe there's
irritation from wearing glue on my head
every single day a product like this
really helps me like make it to a
Starbucks without looking like an
absolute piece of how it's always worked
for me so thank you so much for checking
out my essential items here at GQ and if
you'd like to see any of these
in action please come see my show Trixie
Mattel grown up all over the United
States in Europe or listen to my album
Barbara now on iTunes Amazon and spot